Speaker 1: Let's go next to Charlie from Bayfield,
Colorado. Now, Charlie, is Bayfield one of
the blue parts of Colorado or one of the red
parts?
Speaker 4: Extremely red.
Speaker 1: OK, gotcha. All right, well, go
ahead.
Speaker 4: Hey, man, so I had had a little
commentary I wanted to make, if you would
play along for a second, OK? Can you spell
the word? Ah, can you say the word S. a U.S.
Speaker 1: s a u. S e.
Speaker 4: Or see my bad see?
Speaker 1: Oh, that's Soss, right?
Speaker 4: OK, what about the word A, you
are A,
Speaker 1: that is Ora.
Speaker 4: Or OK, interesting, I'm just I'm
just kind of weirded out about how you always
mispronounce Vache his name after he told
you what it is.
Speaker 1: Oh, it's just a it's just an ongoing
joke. That's all it is. And I think he says
Pakman as well or something like that. It's
just a joke.
Speaker 4: Is it not Pakman,
Speaker 1: it's Pakman, not Pakman.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah, oh, funny, so just a
little back and forth between you guys. Yeah,
it's just a joke. Oh, hey, I was just I was
so I was I was upset because I was just I
was hoping it wasn't some gig exchange on
your part, so.
Speaker 1: No, no, no. We have a strict no
gig cringe policy on this show.
Speaker 4: OK, OK, OK, I believe it, I believe
that, which is
Speaker 1: why I'm going to have to, which
is why I'm going to have to let you
Speaker 4: go.
Speaker 1: OK, and Charlie bailed, all right,
wow, clipart, that's quite a quite a phone
call. OK, let's continue here. Let's go next
to Miles from Bay City, Michigan.
Speaker 3: Hello, Mr. Brackman, can you hear
me?
Speaker 1: Just barely, Miles, I'm going to
crank you up as loud as I can. How about Neuhauser,
it's marginally better.
Speaker 3: More and more comment on observations
I've been seeing, you know, since I've been
working back in the office, I mean, I've been
kind of appalled by the amount of people that
are hanging flags or having decorations that
are. You know, having profanities like F bomb
Joe Biden is just like, really,
Speaker 1: I know it's like very it's like
a continued coarsening of the discourse. I
saw a video earlier today of a guy just walking
through a retail store with an F Biden flag.
And it's less about like, I don't care. You
know, I don't care about the profanity. But
these are these are what I call Acebes. These
are attention seeking behaviors. And very
often there's like something going on emotionally
for the people that do it, because f Biden,
you know, this is not I feel really strongly
about abortion and I'm against it. Right.
I would disagree with you, but at least it's
sort of like substantive, at least ostensibly.
But F Biden, it's just an attention seeking
behavior. And I almost sometimes wonder whether
it's better not to give it any attention,
not to even acknowledge it.
Speaker 3: I mean, I can definitely understand
that aspect, but I don't know, maybe it's
just my growing up as a kid, you know, I don't
recall seeing anything of this or to where
it's just like I grew up in a Christian household,
you know, even saying, you know, any even
lesser swear word was a very punishable. So
the fact that, you know, there are kids out
there today that kind of see this stuff and
I don't know if kids are like me, when I was
growing up, I'd see something and I'd repeat
it. So it's just a matter of. Oh, great. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, I don't have I don't have
that hang up. Like, I don't really worry about
kids seeing profanity. You know, in many countries,
TV has profanity and it's just like no big
deal. So for me it's less about that. It's
just that the discourse is getting stupider
and stupider. And people don't understand
the difference between what kind of a statement
is a factual statement and what kind of a
statement is is a statement of opinion. And
we're really just losing our ability to even
disagree because people misunderstand what
it even means to have an opinion disagreement
versus to be unable to establish the facts
of something. So for me, it's more of like
a structural problem.
Speaker 3: Very understandable. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, I appreciate your time, so
let me ask you, so when you see the Biden
flags that coworkers have, do you acknowledge
it or mention it in any way or just ignore
it?
Speaker 3: Thankfully, none of my coworkers
do is just I got quite a commute to the office,
so. Oh, one more. It's more along the lines
of as I'm going to work and passing through.
I got off like that go. And it's to me it's
still just a little eyebrow raising again.
It's just the amount of profanities and it's
just like, come on, think of I don't know.
Speaker 1: For the children, thing is an important
part, it sounds like, exactly on.
Speaker 3: Not it's not it's not a paid job,
it's part of a hobby, but I helped teach martial
arts and, you know, I have a sore spot for
kids. You know, I want to make sure I teach
them good things and stuff like that outside
of martial arts. So at that point, when I
see that stuff, like, I guess they don't care
about kids seeing that kinda stuff. I mean,
I've seen one where it's the same kind of
fire, except it says Impeach Biden. I'm sure,
like you at least have the decency to not
use profanities.
Speaker 1: At least that's ostensibly a political
statement. Yeah. All right, my friend, while
I appreciate the perspective. Thank you.
Speaker 3: All right. Thank you, sir. All
right.
Speaker 1: Let's take a quick pause. If you're
holding on to talk to me and you continue
to want to talk to me, if you've not been
dissuaded yet, just hang on, because we're
going right back to the phones momentarily.